Sie sehen, das hier ist eine
ziemliche grosse Menge an Paste.
Mhm.
Sie deckt relativ gut ab.
Es ist fast wie eine Maske.
Und, ähm ...
- Was haben Sie abgedeckt?
Die blauen Augen, die blauen ...
Was immer ich im Gesicht hatte.
Die blauen Flecken.
Oder je nachdem auch gelbe Flecken.
Rote Kratzer.
Was auch immer
gerade zum Vorschein kam.
Dieses Make-up
deckt einfach viel besser ab.
Weshalb hatten Sie solche Flecken?
Wegen ihm: von den Schlägen,
vom Kratzen, von ... ach ...
... von verschiedenen Tätlichkeiten.
Immer wieder.
* Pulsierende Musikschläge *
Weshalb sind Sie geblieben?
Dachten Sie, das sei Liebe?
Ja, indirekt.
Er hat sich immerhin
mit mir befasst.
Ähm ...
Es ist so schwierig,
das zu erklären.
Über dieses Phänomen
werde ich oft gefragt -
und ich kann nicht antworten,
keine Antwort geben.
Sie haben auch jetzt
noch keine Antwort darauf.
Hoffnung, wahrscheinlich.
Als ich dieses Kleid trug ...
Wir hatten so eine schöne Hochzeit.
Ich freute mich so,
mit diesem Mann zusammenzubleiben,
eine Familie zu gründen,
ein Haus zu bauen.
Die typisch schweizerischen Ideen:
Haus, Kind ...
Irgendwo zu Hause zu sein,
ein Zuhause zu haben.
Mein Schleier
reichte bis auf den Boden.
Es war eigentlich
eine perfekte Hochzeit.
Sie war wunderschön.
Was auffällt:
Da ist meine Nase noch gerade.
Jetzt ist sie ja
immer noch gebrochen.
Nur zum Sagen:
Sie war mal sehr gerade.
Wie oft ist die Nase gebrochen?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Dreimal sicher.
Nach der Geburt.
Der gemeinsame Sohn - ein Wunschkind.
Als Tochter
eines Schweizer Diplomaten
war Corinne T.
auf der halben Welt zu Hause.
Ein Baby, ein Ehemann, ein Eigenheim.
Die Direktionsassistentin
schien endlich angekommen.
Das ist ein hübsches Foto
mit meinem Mann.
Da feierten wir
erstmals Weihnachten.
Da war so ... ja.
Wann kam die Kehrtwende?
Die Anzeichen
waren immer ein bisschen sichtbar.
Wirklich gewendet hat es sich
bei der Geburt des Kindes.
Wie ich sagte, ich denke ...
Vermutlich habe ich mich nicht mehr
genügend um ihn gekümmert.
Er hat sich nie geäussert.
Er hat nie gesagt:
"Was ist mit mir?"
Wie hat er sich dann geäussert?
Mit Frust.
Alkohol wurde
zu einem grossen Thema.
Er ist öfters ausgegangen,
was mir nicht passte.
Ich schrie ihn an.
Er kam während der Woche an
einem Dienstag besoffen nach Hause,
um 1 Uhr morgens.
Dann hat es angefangen.
Das ist der letzte Spitalbericht.
Da ging es wirklich um mein Leben.
Da steht auch:
"alkoholisiert,
mehrmals verprügelt."
"Gewürgt, mit Fäusten ins Gesicht
geschlagen", das ist das.
"Übelkeit, Erbrechen,
Nasenbeinbruch", usw.
"Faust ins Gesicht".
Wie oft waren Sie im Spital?
Zu wenig.
Nur etwa siebenmal.
Sieben-, achtmal. Nicht mehr.
Aber es gab mehr ...
- ... Übergriffe und Gewalt.
Natürlich nicht so schlimm. Ich ging
erst ins Spital, als es schlimm war.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass es einmal so weit kommt.
Vermutlich
habe ich zu lange gekämpft.
Hätte ich weniger lange gekämpft,
wäre es nicht so ausgeartet.
Wäre ich früher gegangen,
wäre es nie so weit gekommen.
Aber weil ich geblieben bin, ist es
schlimmer geworden und ausgeartet.
Der Sohn ist mittlerweile
ein Teenager. Auf seinen Wunsch hin
wird in diesem Film nicht näher
auf seine Situation eingegangen.
Nach zwölf Jahren Ehehölle
gelang Corinne T. der Ausstieg.
Zusammen mit ihrem Sohn
flüchtete sie ins Frauenhaus.
Wir treffen die damalige Leiterin.
Zum Schutz werden an dieser Stelle
weder das Frauenhaus,
noch die Mitarbeiterinnen gezeigt.
Gehen wir ein wenig über die Brücke?
- Ja, okay, alles klar.
Ich war so dankbar, dass ich damals
vom Frauenhaus aufgenommen wurde.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich
mehrere Anläufe gemacht habe.
Man hat mich immer gefragt,
ob ich unmittelbar in Gefahr sei.
Ich antwortete: "Eigentlich nicht,
er schläft jetzt wieder."
"Er ist betrunken
und liegt im Bett."
Alle zwei Wochen
stirbt in der Schweiz eine Person
infolge häuslicher Gewalt,
die meisten davon sind Frauen.
Im letzten Jahr registrierte
die Polizei rund 17'000 Straftaten
im Bereich partnerschaftlicher
oder familiärer Beziehungen.
Doch: Noch immer holt
ein Grossteil der Betroffenen
keine Hilfe von aussen.
Die Scham, darüber zu reden,
ist bei Betroffenen, bei Opfern
von häuslicher Gewalt, sehr gross.
Warum?
Weil es beschämend ist,
dass einem selbst das passiert.
Gerade auch Frauen wie Frau...
* Piepen *
die das nie in ihrem Leben ...
Sie dachte nicht, dass ihr
das jemals passieren könnte.
Ich hatte Staatsanwältinnen
als Klientinnen.
Ich habe Ärztinnen, Psychologinnen,
Politikerinnen. Alle.
Die glaubten nie,
dass ihnen das passieren könnte.
Wenn sie nicht
gleich gegangen sind ...
Wenn es eine längere Zeit dauerte,
bis sie sich
daraus befreien konnten,
ist es unglaublich beschämend, dass
man das mit sich hat machen lassen.
Ja, man schämt sich.
Man will ja
die perfekte Familie vorzeigen.
Wir haben das in der Öffentlichkeit
auch vorgezeigt.
Das ist eine Art Mechanismus.
Man will zeigen,
dass alles in Ordnung ist,
und man will
nicht als Versager dastehen.
Ich habe mich schon so gefühlt,
als ob ich versagt hätte.
Warum gehen die Frauen nicht?
Das ist natürlich
eine sehr komplexe Frage.
Es gibt ganz verschiedene Gründe.
In erster Linie
ist es eigentlich so,
dass die Frauen den Mann geheiratet
haben oder mit ihm zusammen sind,
weil sie ihn lieben.
D.h., es gibt eine emotionale Ebene.
Es ist dann so unfassbar,
dass es so kippt.
Es sind dann schon der Versuch
und die Hoffnung da,
dass es wieder gut werden könnte.
"Eigentlich will ich mich
ja nicht trennen,
sondern ich will eigentlich,
dass die Gewalt aufhört."
Es dauert lange,
bis sie realisieren,
dass sie es
gar nicht verhindern können.
Es passiert irgendwann,
dass Frauen das für sich annehmen:
"Ja, ich habe schon ... Wenn ich das
nicht gemacht oder gesagt hätte,
dann wäre er nicht so explodiert."
Sie sind bereit, zumindest einen
Teil der Schuld auf sich zu nehmen.
So hat man noch ein wenig
die Kontrolle über die Situation.
* Pulsierende Musikschläge *
Was lösen die Bilder in Ihnen aus,
wenn Sie sie nun anschauen?
(Mit verfremdeter Stimme)
Was soll das auslösen?
Es löst ganz klar aus,
was für ein Arsch man ist.
Ich schäme mich derartig,
was auch mehr als recht ist.
Es ist nicht normal,
das macht man nicht.
Ein normaler Mensch
macht so etwas nicht.
Sie haben es gemacht.
- Ich weiss.
Ich weiss, dass ich es gemacht habe.
Es geht mir immer durch den Kopf.
Das Warum?
- Das Warum, das Wieso?
Was führte dazu? Wo hätte man
etwas anders machen können?
Auch für ihn
war es eine Liebeshochzeit.
Unerklärlich,
wie die anfängliche Zuneigung
schleichend zur Gewalt wurde,
ausartete.
Bis Corinne T. ihren Mann
nach einer brutalen Prügelattacke
schliesslich
bei der Polizei anzeigte.
Ihr Mann besuchte daraufhin
ein Gewaltprogramm.
Diese Massnahme vermochte die Bezieh-
ung aber auch nicht mehr zu retten.
(Mit verfremdeter Stimme)
Man muss bei solchen Dingen sehen,
wie sie angefangen haben
und wie sie ausgeartet sind.
Vielleicht bräuchte man selbst
auch Hilfe, weil es zu viel wird.
Man ist sich gar nicht bewusst,
wo man hineinschlittert -
immer mehr und immer mehr.
Aber das ist nicht das Problem.
Das Problem entsteht dann, wenn man
die ganze Nacht terrorisiert wird,
bis in den frühen Morgen hinein,
bis sie sich
nicht mehr besinnen kann.
Nicht ich - sie!
Das können Sie sich
nicht vorstellen!
Das müssen Sie erlebt haben -
und zwar nicht nur einmal.
Das müssen Sie wiederholt erleben,
dann können Sie vielleicht
etwas nachvollziehen,
was in einem vorgeht.
Es ist schon Gewalt, mich die ganze
Nacht nicht schlafen zu lassen,
nur damit es nach ihrem Kopf geht.
Aber es gibt doch eine Grenze,
ob man laut ist und streitet,
oder ob man jemanden schlägt.
Die Grenze gibt es ein Stück weit,
da haben Sie recht,
aber das Problem ist ... Es heisst
immer, das dürfe man nicht.
Aber alles andere ist erlaubt?
Das sehe ich nicht so!
Das davor ist nicht erlaubt.
An den Haaren reissen
ist keine Zärtlichkeit -
apropos Gewalt.
D.h. nicht, dass Sie Ihre Frau
auch schlagen mussten,
bis zu einem Nasenbeinbruch, z.B.
Wenn sie mich angreift und mir eins
an die Nase haut oder sonst etwas,
dann muss ich mich wehren.
Haben Sie gegenüber Ihrem Mann
auch Übergriffe, Gewalt ausgeübt?
Nein, nie.
Körperliche Gewalt: nicht einmal.
Wir hatten natürlich
normale Streitgespräche.
Aber angefasst ... Ich habe ihn
vielleicht einmal geschüttelt.
Als er betrunken im Bett lag,
sagte ich, ich würde ihn verlasen.
Das habe ich gemacht,
ich habe ihn einmal geschüttelt.
Keine tätlichen Übergriffe?
- Nein.
Nie geschlagen. Nichts.
Nie.
Vielleicht
hätte ich mich wehren sollen.
Aber das hätte
verheerende Folgen gehabt.
Verheerende Folgen.
Fast vier Jahre sind nun vergangen,
seit Corinne T.
sich von ihrem Mann trennte.
Die Scheidung
ist noch immer nicht vollzogen.
Heute steht
ein weiterer Gerichtstermin an.
Sie sehen gleich Ihren Noch-Ehmann.
Wie ist das für Sie?
Furchtbar! Wuah!
Nur schon wenn Sie es erwähnen ...
Ich habe
gar nicht mehr daran gedacht.
Ich werde ihn nicht anschauen,
ich werde auf den Boden schauen.
Ich kann es nicht.
Die Anzeige gegen ihren Mann
wegen Körperverletzung und Drohung
hat Corinne T. zurückgezogen -
was sie im Nachhinein bitter bereut.
In diesen Tagen stimmte der National-
rat einer Gesetzesverschärfung zu:
Neu sollen Opfer von Beziehungsgewalt
nicht mehr allein bestimmen,
ob die Anzeige
zurückgezogen werden kann.
Für Corinne T.
kommt diese Regelung zu spät.
Finden Sie es gut,
wenn extern darüber bestimmt wird,
ob die Anzeige zurückgezogen wird?
- Auf jeden Fall.
Warum?
Weil man nach solchen Erlebnissen
nicht in der Verfassung ist,
klar zu urteilen. Das ist unmöglich.
Man befindet sich
in einer Art Abhängigkeit.
Man kann gar nicht klar beurteilen.
Sie haben die Anzeige zurückgezogen.
Warum?
Aus mehreren Gründen:
Es war Weihnachtszeit,
alle Familien vereint.
Alles war schön,
die Kinder hatten Freude
und ich war dort zu Hause.
Blau geschlagen und alles.
Ich dachte: "Ach, komm.
Geben wir ihm nochmals eine Chance!"
Seit der Trennung verkehrt Corinne T.
mit ihrem Ehemann
nur noch schriftlich.
Dass sie ihm heute
zum ersten Mal wieder begegnen wird,
belastet sie sehr.
Ich kann es kaum ertragen.
Meine Haut ist so dünn,
ich ertrage es nicht mehr.
Ich warte seit vier Jahren
auf diese verd...
Scheisse, er steht dort!
Ich halte es nicht aus.
Können Sie rasch rauskommen?
Ich möchte nicht alleine rein.
Okay, bis später. Adieu.
Nur in Begleitung ihres Anwalts
schafft es Corinne T.
an den Verhandlungstisch.
Wieder wird gestritten:
um das Sorgerecht
und um den Verkauf
des gemeinsamen Hauses.
Eine Einigung -
und somit eine baldige Scheidung  -
liegt in weiter Ferne.
(Mann) Geht's?
Das ist anstrengend.
- Das ist Sport.
Vor gut drei Jahren lernte Corinne T.
ihren heutigen Partner kennen,
im Internet.
Es ist gut, schon gut.
Eric Z. ist Polizist.
Bilder der Gewalt
kennt er zwar von seiner Arbeit.
Was es aber konkret heisst, mit
einer Frau eine Beziehung zu führen,
die geprügelt und gedemütigt wurde,
ist auch für ihn neu.
Dementsprechend
war der Start schwierig.
Am Anfang war einfach
der Vertrauensaufbau sehr schwierig.
Ihr glaubhaft machen zu können,
dass ich es nicht böse meine.
Dass ich es ernst meine
und auch jemanden suche,
mit dem ich den Rest meines Lebens
zusammen sein kann.
Einfach jemanden zu haben,
ein Paar zu sein.
Das Bedürfnis hatte ich,
und ich schmeisse nicht etwas weg,
weil in ihrem Leben etwas passiert
ist, wofür sie nicht viel kann.
Man baut weiter.
Wir sind keine Teenager,
die sich gleich wieder trennen.
Etwas Ausdauer habe ich schon.
Ich habe nicht mehr daran geglaubt,
dass man mich überhaupt lieben kann.
Das war gar nicht mehr möglich.
Wenn man immer gedemütigt wird,
glaubt man, nichts wert zu sein.
Kein Verlust.
Dann merkt man: "Der hat mich gern.
Oh, was mache ich jetzt?"
Das könnte noch sein.
- Scheisse.
Es ist lustig, aber wahr.
So ist das.
Mhm.
- Ja.
Am liebsten
möchte ich nicht daran denken,
sondern den schönen Ort geniessen.
Vorwärtsgehen, vorwärtsschauen.
Was bedeutet vorwärtsgehen
für Sie beide?
Vorwärtsschauen?
Helfen, diese Erinnerungen
irgendwie verarbeiten zu können,
damit wir
einen neuen Weg gehen können.
Die Vergangenheit
langsam in den Hintergrund stellen.
Es ist eine Belastung
für die Beziehung,
wenn das Thema immer da ist.
Irgendwann muss ich abschliessen,
aber es ist viel besser.
Werden Sie es einmal abschliessen?
Ja, aber ich werde es
nie vergessen können.
Es wird immer ein Teil von mir sein,
lebenslänglich.
* Pulsierende Musikschläge *
Die Frau so zuzurichten? Puh!
Wie ist das möglich?
Das begreife ich nicht.
Er kann es manchmal nicht verstehen,
dass ich nicht gegangen bin.
Es ist für ihn unerklärlich.
Es ist für mich die schlimmste Fra-
ge, warum ich nicht gegangen bin
oder warum ich
die Anzeige zurückgezogen habe.
Das tut mir richtig weh,
aber er hat recht.
Es ist so. Warum?
Aber was will ich machen?
Es ist vorbei,
ich kann es nicht mehr ändern.
Ich habe es gemacht.
Immerhin bin ich noch gegangen.
Es gibt viele, die gar nicht gehen.
Ja, du bist gegangen. Spät.
Nach zwölf Jahren.
Oh!
- Mhm.
Am Schluss
bin ich wegen zwei Wörtern gegangen.
Zwei Wörter.
Er drehte sich zu mir.
Ich weinte, war am Boden zerstört.
Magenschmerzen, alles.
Er schüttelte den Kopf und sagte:
"Kein Verlust".
Und dann ... Diese zwei Wörter
waren ausschlaggebend,
dass ich zum Telefon ging
und beim Frauenhaus anrief.
Am Schluss
waren es nur die zwei Wörter.
Ich merkte,
er hatte nichts mehr für mich übrig.
Es ist mir sehr klar geworden,
dass ich ihm nichts wert bin.
Ja.
Erst dann konnten Sie gehen?
- Ja, wegen diesen zwei Wörtern.
Das war natürlich ein Prozess
über all die Jahre.
Aber am Schluss
waren es effektiv diese zwei Wörter.
Dann bin ich aufgestanden.
Schau, es gibt riesige Flocken.